today is pre-production for this video
Jake wants to shoot mom which means that
we're shooting it in here
therefore we have to move all the desks
somewhere else which is really annoying
I like my desk where it is I didn't say
it was mine
I've just got two three four seven Union
sucky-suck and oh yes few more to go
Sonny got me no it is we have it dude
check this out this is a printer look
how small this thing is this is the
school of plastic it season to this melt
here and then squirts out and makes a
littler little things the nose on em
love them more of an amenity I mean I
disagree but it seems epsilon free for
the new weenie mission poultry yeah it's
an M it stands for monoprice the M key
Nikko hey I love it just like an see
your printer this is the monoprice
select mini this is lucky eats best
enhance confirm that you said it so if
you don't know much about 3d printers
you have some videos to watch from our
previous year
this thing is $200 this is as cheap as
like an inkjet printer you get at Best
Buy consumer level pricing for 3d
printing and so I was like I have to
have one I always knew someday I'd get
into 3d printing myself with my own
personal printer and the day has finally
come
and this is it now wait till it prints a
new room do it for you it takes your
money in your wife and your dog
I have done nothing with it I literally
pulled it out of a box plugged it in put
the SD card in and started printing so
what it does is it takes a thousand
cross sections of a 3d model and lays
that down here's a Yoda this is the
second thing I printed and it printed
flawlessly mmm
this thing has been going nonstop since
I got it Sunday night basically every
night while I sleep it prints and then
every day well here at the studio at
prints then I come back home rent and
repeat this is an elliptical gear there
is no central access to this and they're
not round but yet they're still
operating like a normal gear this is
probably the coolest thing I've printed
so far it looks like a bunch of you can
get too close you have to be straight on
I turn it on its side it's all in your
head Mikko there's a couple like kind of
big-name actors in the show those girls
who are in those other big shows and
stuff I don't know if I go get their
names from the show that is Commission
like famous people what's it like
working with someone who's like I've
done a lot of stuff that you see me in
but we need to be professional how do
you be professional when you want to
geek out I don't kick out because it's
my job to like actually make sure
they're doing what I need them to do and
delivering the proper story beats that
we need to get but they're also very
good at it so I basically just let them
walk on set I go can I see it I'm gonna
do the same like that's pretty cool and
that's about the extent of what I do
think about like is that a must
president mostly all I do is tell them
when to change it up cool you got it we
nail that let's keep it funky now try
they're like what's like the biggest
difference between like a good like
expensive actor versus a non good actor
good afternoon around acting blockings
and make up your costume how to have
your lines perhaps the flow of set eye
lines to camera so if I'm talking to
somebody they like leaned over I know to
move over so they can still be seen by
the camera finding your light so that if
there's a shadow you move so that you're
back in your light we are shooting six
pages a day and at that speed you're
going to do about three cakes it takes
me to be good from the first cake we'll
do some rehearsals beforehand before the
cameras roll what's the cameras start
rolling the person needs to be on and in
character not screwing up the line good
enough to roll back and like hit the
line again it's something
happens like a plane flies by or
something so good actors just to make
you work fat most of my direction I'm
set is honestly just pushing people just
get into the emotions a little bit more
it's hard to commit to painful emotions
if you're doing a sad scene you know and
they'll do a good job getting into it at
a base level and sometimes just like
note go a little harder delve a little
bit deeper into your internal sorrows
you know unless you're on the right
track
yeah you're doing what you're supposed
to do but you're not hitting it keep
going yep if you put a light in here
it'll project light out as squares on
the ground around it you did it look at
it a 200 all our printer prizes and for
all intents and purposes smallest if you
don't count all the flaws you see if my
phone light will work hey actually holy
crap that works really well look at
these square light mm-hmm I've made
square light dude it's important to note
that I haven't actually modelled any of
these things myself I've literally been
downloading up from a website called
skinny verse what would you even call it
everyone can just kind of users submit
their own universes like all these
models are just like free models that
you can download people have just
donated them to this website here's this
like baby group and I loaded it up in
this program called Kiera you have a
program that you model stuff in but then
you need another program or plugins that
can take that model and make it ready
for printing the support structures and
putting it in the right format for the
printer to read going to print the head
in the body of baby route separately
thank you this over here what that is
take this this is not a sponsor like at
all this is actually something I'm
really interested in this is this was
like really cool eeep so once this heats
up to 210 degrees it's going to start
laying a bed of plastic and that's
called a wrap baby Gert will literally
just sit on that little baby the first a
little bit so this should take maybe
three hours we'll come back in three
hours see the time lapse I mean I think
they have three sets of directing that I
approach
I have my directing for the actor which
is the decisions are making as a
character is important emotional dates
like you might be saying thank you but
really me inside is Bucky so yeah you
know things like that a good actor
already has all stuff prepped the other
the direct thing I need to do is for the
crew and the camera saying okay I need
to set decorated like this and looking
for this kind of temperature on the life
props in the background me to be here
let's put the camera over here space all
the crew direction look for CDs
responsibilities it's his responsibility
but I communicate through him most the
time you talk to ad you don't actually
talk to the gaffers and the prop
positioners specifically I'll be like
I'm looking for this I'm looking for
this and look for this then he's the guy
with inbuilt who makes it happen
when it comes to camera team I talked to
the director of photography he talked to
the camera team so I talked to Adrian he
talked to the camera team and the
lighting team in the group team then my
third and final level of directions
audience direction at the beginning of
the scene I want people to think
everything's fine and dandy and by the
end of the scene I want the audience to
realize that there's a much bigger
problem that no one has realized so they
need to make sure that my whole theme
plays into that story direction of the
audience direction what the audience
willing to take away and sometimes I'll
show that with the actor isn't really I
want the audience to take away from the
scene that you guys truly love each
other that you really want you to focus
on making each other laugh july's
smiling like alucard
I know so that's my direction for the
audience and I'll share that with people
as I need to I don't know I no idea I
never dealt with foggers before probably
use the floor is just like what does a
lit fogger we used before was mine
gotcha yeah
that's quite one day oh you got you all
right so it's done it took an hour and
49 minutes little baby bear so I'm going
to go ahead and just peel it off the bed
with my fingertips
there you go all of you got strings
sticking out of his eye either way I'll
have to the size waist smaller of a
print bed a little bit of a flow and a
friend time but for the freaking price
regardless of price I feel like this is
a pretty good quality print I wish our
printer was working so I could print
something individually hidden parrot but
the problem is my printer won't finish
so there's no comparison to be made good
all right shoot going to put the head on
oh it's got like a little groove in
there to make sure it goes in at the
right angle a grip groove that little
baby Groot an owl and a half print on
the printer I just broke it like
beautiful like terminator thing okay
here somebody broke